i tell you what my father used to do
when i was a kid and he asked me to walk
in our garden to do gardening which i
hated
he said you are an ambitious lazy person
you are thinking how how to do things
easier
[Music]
daddy promoter thank you so much for
joining me on my show how
are you i'm good very well working
extremely efficiently from home
working excellent you don't have to walk
from meeting to meeting you you must be
saving some time
yeah i love it and you're walking i'm
walking more
it's not that's what i that's what i
hear a lot but and now i'm actually you
know i'm curious to see what will happen
you know as we move forward you know the
productivity increases but whether we'll
get some fatigue from this
i think it will be a very interesting
question but daddy you know
i i'm not going to waste time talking
about what's happening now because
i have the honor and pleasure of
speaking to er to
you now you spent over 30 years at intel
corporation your la
your last activity there was acting as
executive vice president
and chief product officer of intel
corporation
daddy just you know to for for my ears
how many people are at intel
you know globally around or at least
when you were there
about 100 000 about 100 000 people as
executive vice president and cpo
i believe i saw somewhere that about 30
000 people were
under your command 35 000 35 000.
you know i'm going to spend 20 minutes
on on a single question but actually i
have many more questions but
what is it like running 35 000 people
as executive vice president of intel
it's very difficult and i think
that's why i can walk from remote much
easier because
you'll find out that you have i you know
andy grove
said something when you manage something
so complex so far
uh you have to influence people because
you cannot talk to each person
and change his mind so you have to be
much more into influencing
show example be very precise and very
concise about
what you say and how you say i added my
israeli officer that you have to be
in the lines every once in a while to
talk to people in the line to make sure
that you know exactly what they
are because the problem is that you will
filter the information from your people
uh which is very important so i think
that you know it's such a rare
opportunity to speak to somebody who's
who's managed 35 000 people you know i
often ask entrepreneurs and founders
about leadership and about you know what
is it like running a team of you know 12
13 people as you go through the trenches
of a startup
you know what are the difficulties and
the challenges of running 35 000 people
i mean how do you
lead a group of 35 000 people do they
know you
do they do they know who who daddy is
are you are you just you know this guy
in the background making the decisions
how does it work
well i manage also five six people came
so i know the difference it's a huge
difference
when you manage five six ten people
usually that you're all together and if
you've started
you mostly know many of the people for
years and you're good friends of them
right and it's different when you run 35
you know across uh probably four
continents or something like that
uh i learned something from that some
someone asked mahatma gandhi how do you
lead 400 million people
at the time there have been only 400
million indians
at the time he said i'm not leading them
i'm seeing where the people are running
and i'm just running in front of them uh
you you come to realize that most of the
people
other than people that work very closely
with you and with many of the people
i've been working for
for you know dozens of years
uh the people have the persona of you
they have the impression of who you are
which may not be oh probably not exactly
who you are
uh or as i said you know people have
many personas
it's not that you are a schizophrenic or
something like that but you have many
personas because
you know my kids see a different uh
daddy than my wife is and where my
friends are
and my employees are but at the end of
the day you're the same person
uh my leadership style that i'm open and
direct
people know what i mean when i say they
don't have to
second-guess me makes it easier for them
to understand what i'm talking about
that's my view you don't trick them and
you show by example is it possible to
open and direct with 30 000 people
yes because uh if you admit when you
make mistakes
and well if you do it every day it's a
problem right
i don't want to be led by an idiot that
you know
change his mind every day but you know
every once in a while you make a bad
move and
you know human beings make bad decisions
uh i believe that a good leader is not
the one that does not make a
mistake because all people are
is verb admit openly about the mistake
learn from the mistakes and you know
direct a new course of action because
not because
uh you don't know what to do you know
maybe you're idiots but i'm also
part of the team of idiots and
this is why i made a mistake this is
what happened
this is what i'm going to do next and i
have a good
big lecture about this one but uh
migrated achievement you know
intel israeli greatest zero was based on
a big failure that we learned
from the mistake and uh applied you know
the whole intel notebook
you know the centrino program was based
on a failed program
that was called name timna and
it was a big failure and a huge success
and today it's a core core part and part
of
all the other yeah now it is the
foundation of what became the core
but as a matter of fact at that time
people only 50
people use notebooks so you know
90 of people buy notebooks when they use
a personal computer
i was i was having an a wonderful
conversation the other day with gil
frostig who you probably know from from
intel as well
and he's a very good friend here from j
ventures and we were talking about you
know his endeavors with wi-fi chips and
and how you know that also came from
from not a mistake but but
some some you know a consequence that he
did not expect
but you know daddy i want to take you
then back to you're the technion you're
studying electrical engineering you're
joining intel
eventually you you come to speak about
how one of the great things about this
this cooperation between intel and the
technolon is that
while they're both situated in very
close proximity
but but the best and the brightest from
the techno and often go to work at intel
and and you ha and you know you're
creating something very special there
within the startup nation take me back
to those times you join intel
do you have an aspiration to go and
spend over 30 years at this great
corporation
and and rise the ladder of success to be
you know one of the executives
is that intentional no i came
i came to intel as a compromise because
i really wanted to be an academic i want
to be a professor
so you settled for going on a career
path for an executive
i was married very young i basically
married when i studied in the technion
i had the eldest my eldest son was
already born
and when talking to meyer said i want to
go to do my masters and then phd
she said well you know we are in a bad
financial situation
we have to get stable a little bit and
we decided that i'll go to work at intel
and continues my studies as
an external student wow and
maybe two three years we'll get
stabilized
i never finished my master's degree and
i spent 34 years at intel
but every three four years was a
completely different journey so
and and that doesn't stop you from now
teaching thousands of
uh teaching and inspiring thousands on
the coursera course that i came that i
came across
so i think that you know the master's
degree the master's degree will wait
daddy you know i want to i want to make
sure we have enough time for this i want
to do a transition now to
your to the time after intel and one of
the things that is very evident when you
look at your background and the things
that you're doing is that you're very
passionate about
social entrepreneurship social
innovation both as the chairman of
chairman of the board of michelano we're
also chairman of the board of israel
innovation authority and i'm probably
missing a bunch of others that
that i didn't mention here talk what is
this transition from
an executive vice president at intel to
being the chairman of the board of these
organizations and what does that even
mean being the chairman of the board
for me it is very simple because it's
the same thing
uh basically the one thing that
eventually got me to stay tinted because
i wanted my dream was to to make things
that changed the world
that's my dream since i was a child i
thought i'll do it as an academic then
as an engineer
eventually as an executive in a big
company uh
but there are other things to do other
than computing and basically
computing and technology could be used
for bettings
in many cases but also for good things
and
you know i'm focusing on israel but most
of these problems are
worldwide dishes and basically my wife
and i decided that we devote
big portion of our time and all of our
philanthropic investment into
social entrepreneurship uh predominantly
in education
closing social gaps giving opportunities
and combining or making
communities closer so one of the the i'm
a chairman also
a non-profit that deals with bringing
the arab community in israel into
israeli high tech wow it's all it's it's
all it's all the same
uh you know people are different but
it's all about working with people with
motivation to do great things
so you know inspire me a little with
some of the things that you're that
you're deeply passionate about some
things that you know i
as a young entrepreneur now here in palo
alto or from tel aviv that i might not
be exposed to on a day-to-day basis
these are these are issues that are very
close to my heart as well because
you know but all the way through high
school in the military i was also very
active and very passionate
at bringing together various communities
but but i'd love to get your take
because now you're
you're getting an exposure at this from
you know from an executive level
as you're overseeing a lot of these
organizations that are doing really
amazing impact
so what are some of the things that as a
young entrepreneur can take with me and
understand better about my society
and what is my potential role as a
leader as i go
into you know the high-tech industry
hopefully make
positive impact but i i also have a
social responsibility to bridge together
communities
and not be a bystander and let the same
you know circle of effect
take place unfortunately the world is
using
for possibilities for you if you want to
do things uh
we picked education because um
education at the end of the day is the
uh you could argue
master's degree yes no and but this is
for most of the
kids in the world this is uh
just you know every child have a huge
intelligence i don't think you know in
the us they have the saying that
we could uh very much uh anticipate your
success
in school and in life based on the zip
code
and the zip code is not as an indicator
of how how wealthy
your parents are it's nothing to do with
you your intelligence your abilities
so giving opportunities if you want to
change the world
one of the ways which takes longer is to
give opportunities for kids in school
and it's amazing one of the
organizations that are doing they take
schools in
in the wrong zip codes and it's amazing
how smart the team of people with
relatively small amount of money
are able to make changes from a 20
success
in academic uh
successes into eighty and even ninety
percent
in three four years so it's what is what
is the changing factor
what what changes from twenty to eighty
percent you know it's it's
it it's a complex way but it's a very
much a very systematic view of people
that understand education
combined with people that come from the
high-tech community
uh they go it sounds like an engineering
my wife is my wife is an educator she
was a principal of a
special ed school they go in with the
right people
good pedagogy they they do a few things
first the school master is
is the king they are not doing the plans
for him or her
they the ownership is the school master
it's a big difference
in israel especially you know the
minister of education tells the school
master what he needs to do or she
right because she so we i'll use she
from now on
um they bring in a set of
volunteers they come from high-tech
business army 81 and a2
they make miracles in helping kids to go
study you know the highest level of math
and go to
examinations and they are same age give
or take
so it's not the 60 plus you don't tell
them what to do it's their
their older than them it's a big
influence uh we bring what we call
uh a mentor for the school master
someone from
you know we have a an army lieutenant
general is one of those
uh you know he sits there and the school
master calls him and
uh get help and the pedagogic
team comes in and do a deep analysis of
the school not just the
pedagogic and academic
successes uh social situation
the level of the teachers the the the
teamwork between the school bus or the
teachers
uh you know the situation at home many
of these
kids go at home that have one parent and
not two
social economic issues and they
eventually based on this data and they
have
huge amount of information and the
school master always say
i've never seen such a deep analysis to
understand
the school that i'm running for five six
years
and you know it's classical you know
basic engineering call it that way
and then they they support the uh the
schools
we give them some money not a huge
amount but you you
don't come as a consultant you come and
say i'll help you implement the plan
you create so daddy well you know this
is remarkable and inspiring i i see a
dissonance on one hand
you're overseeing an operation of 35 000
people chief product officer of intel
you're running
billions of dollars right in in in terms
of both
talent but also in terms of products so
you're used to making decisions at scale
right like high level like like how do
we
how do we go about the world now you're
talking to me how do we go into a single
school and influence
you know you know kids that you can
count on a piece of paper
and so is that intentional or
because you could be spending your time
right now sitting on the boards of you
know billion
of unicorns that are you know that are
that are dealing with billions of people
and you're choosing to spend your time
and effort
on this mentorship activity for specific
people
well the truth of the matter
one i do also i'm a chairman of two
startups and i'm
also investors and few others so uh
my day is full um my main job in my
daddy i just want to make sure but
when you go and you look and and you
look daddy up online
the passion that what exudes is you're
in your philanthropic activities it's
not the investments and it's not the
board
it's the it's the volunteering work that
you're doing i agree and i'll tell you
what
my main job in this nonprofit my wife do
this
you know she does with 10 schools so she
is a big manager too
um a big challenge and one of the things
that i
work very closely with the ceo of this a
non-profit
an impressive lady um
is about scale because uh
we are now dealing when my wife and i
joined the
we dealt with about seven or eight
schools we're now dealing with 40.
the big uh looks insurmountable right
now is how to influence
the minister of education to change your
mind because at the end of the day
in israel there are about eight hundred
to a thousand schools like that so
wow so 40 so 40 scores it's still
a drop but you know there's an old
saying
in hebrew that the one who saves the
life of one person
is if he changes the life of of save the
life of the whole world
so every kid matters so it's not a small
deal
it's more important than billions of
dollars i always told my ui
that her job in saving kids life
literally
uh in her school amazing is bigger job
than
my billions of dollars but you have to
say
that everything that i do with every
non-profit that i work with
is about scale not just the one person
nevertheless the one person is still
extremely important daddy
so much inspiration here before we leave
a you know you've see
you've been and you've been an integral
part of the startup nation and the
foundation of the startup nation from
its
you know from its early days uh what is
the startup nation what is this miracle
of
of this tech innovation in israel beyond
intel you've seen it you've lived it
why you know why is israel a big tech
hub
well i'll tell you uh first israel is
not south of nation
there is a nation within israel
construct of nation which is about 9
of the people in the country
my job talking just about education
is hopefully to turn the horizon to
startup nation not ever not
mean that everybody walks on the startup
and inventing technology
but the world is becoming more based on
technology and people are not
technology literate are not going to be
able to succeed in this world and the
corona crisis even
exemplified that even further
you know 20 years ago was interviewed
in new delhi they wanted to turn india
into the iit nation
and they talked about intel of course
and all that and his last question was
uh you know that the uh the same
question you ask
what we need to do and i said you know
what you're doing good in israel i said
that means you don't understand israeli
culture if you ask me what's bad in
israel i'll give you
a 15 minutes lecture without even
thinking
give me five minutes to think
you know it's uh it's about the
impatience the
uh wanting to do things better wanting
to do things differently
not being confined to uh to the box
right and uh so you know i said it's
very short but it's very
it's very easily the camaraderie on one
hand
and the personal success on the other
hand so i've seen cultures that
go either on camaraderie or the personal
inspiration
and in israel it's something which is
quite unique it's very difficult to
explain because how can you be
driving your personal success is it on
the expense of the camaraderie
never will be the at the expense of the
team when
especially successful that's one of the
reasons for success
i love it you know when i always think
about this question and you know first i
i
obviously go back to my own military
service and i can't help but remember
all the times where you know i was
leading a team of engineers my commander
would come in and say michael here is
the task we need this
software to be done next week and i'm
saying but you know we need three times
the
the people in order to get this done
he's like ah you'll figure out a way i
trust you come back next
week and obviously figure out a way but
i always also think back to ben gurion
and i
i don't know if it's a myth or if it's a
real story that we ran out of rice
and so he said you know you figure out a
way and that's how he came to
make it my favorite food of all time you
know i had i had a boss
he was chinese a very harsh person
and i came to ask him about give me
about information about competition
at that time was digital at the
and he said what you asking me your
israelis
i'm sure you or one of you guys know
someone in boston that works with
digital and you know the information
come back next month and tell me what
you do
thank you so much for your time i know
you're so busy so i really really want
to thank you
before we leave i need three words that
you would use to describe yourself
i'll tell you what my father used to do
when i was a kid and he asked me to walk
in our garden to do gardening which i
hated
he said you are an ambitious lazy person
you are thinking how how to do things
easier
i love it i love it daddy thank you very
very much
and stay safe and stay healthy and then
really thank you for your time
really appreciate it